いかがですか？はい ありがとうございました
先ほど先生が動物の苦しみを一時的に取ってあげられる
動物の根本的なことですが
それはやっぱり慈しみを送る
ちょっと聞き取れない
鳥やなんかも気持ち悪い時に苦しみを取ってあげたらすっかりなって
太陽を群れで  えっ？ 鳥をリラックスさせる
動物を安らがせてあげるというのは
やっぱり慈しみを送る
慈しみだから怖くないんだと
大丈夫やと 安心させるんです
気持ちを送ってあげれば
それは一人一人研究するしかね
これはこういう方法やというふうにはね
ちょっと言いにくいんですけど
ポイントだけ覚えていけば
自分なりに方法を見つかるんです
だから この二次的な真相の波動がね
動物にははっきりしていますからね
恐怖感ともう不安感というのはね
で 自分が優しい気持ちで触ってみると
その時つかみ方もつかんではいけないんですよ
微妙なんです 猫はバシッと抱っこしちゃうと猫は嫌がるんです
だから子供 猫は子供は天敵やと思ってるんだから
もう子供はもうどこかから突っ張って取るでしょ
猫では最悪なんです しかし
優しく猫が飛んでいこうかなと思ったら飛んでいける
痛いか そのまま抱っこされていたかったらいてもいいという
この微妙なところで抱っこするんです
だから私は猫を抱っこすると
もう出て行きたければすぐ出て行くんです
猫が 飛んでいけばいいんです
そんなしっかり抱かないんです
しかし 猫がガーッとグッといたければいいんです
そうするとちょっと楽にしてあげたりする
しかし 猫に何か問題があって
何か調べる場合は まるっきり身動きできないように捕まるんです
その時でもすぐわかるんです
何か仕事をやってるみたいだと
じゃあ放っておきましょうと
まあとにかく まあそれはそんなに
まあ頑張ってください
はい じゃあえっと お話なんで
思考と妄想  なんか私の耳が遠くなったみたい
えっ？ お話の中でですね
思考と妄想の制御ということが書かれていたと思うんですけども
これはやはり思考と妄想の制御というのは
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をしなさいということと解釈してよろしいでしょうか
うんうん まあそういうことです
うん はい 御隠居さん はい
感覚による一時的な苦痛
はい それが苦というのは痛みという痛みですか？痛みというのは一般的には
痛み 結局は痛みですよ
うん なぜ痛みということを使うかというと
やっぱりこれ嫌なんですよ
だから痛みのあの いろいろ
一だと思いますね あの
痛みもいろいろ種類とかね
もう微妙にあるみたいですけど
結局まとめてみれば痛みなんです
具体的な話でありますと
私は年を取りますとですね
腰痛になりますけどね
老化してくると 腰の椎間板というのがすり切れて痛みを感じる
そうすると 一時的な痛みを感じますと
妄想が起きてですね このままこの痛みになるのではないかと
あれこれ考えましてですね
医者へ行きますとですね
ブロック注射というのがあると
脊椎骨に ん？脊椎骨という骨があるんですけど
はいはいはい  そこに注射を打ってもらうとですね
痛みがこう感じるのをブロック
ブロック注射 はいはいはい
痛みを感じないですね
うん それは先ほどの一時的な感覚なのか
精神的な感覚なのか  それはお医者さんには一時的な感覚しか治療できませんよ
なぜならば 一時的な苦は本物だから
現実だから  そうすると今は私はブロック注射をしてもらって痛みを感じないから
うん 妄想がしないですね
それに続いて二次的な苦は生まれてこないでしょ
先ほどの体の中ではですね
うん ...要するにその椎間板に何か当たって痛いという現象は生じているけれども
それをブロックしてたんですね
うん 私にとっては必ず一時的な感覚はないと
ないじゃない うん だから 1も 2もないわけ
1なくなっちゃうと 2も 3も消えちゃいますよ
しかし 妄想で作ることはできます
もしこのブロック注射したって
私椎間板が悪いでしょうにと
これ危ないでしょうと
そんな薬本当に効くのかというと
また痛みが出てくるんですよ
その場合は お医者さんにはどうすることもできないんです
本物じゃないんだから
自分の二次的な苦しみだから
あの医学の世界でもあります
この何の薬も効かない痛みの患者さんがいるんですよ
あれ 何て言いますかね
何の薬でも何の治療も効かない
しかし 体がむちゃくちゃ痛い
それは二次的な苦しみなんです
だから肉体に痛みがあったら
もういくらでも薬ありますよ
いくらでもあります すごく簡単
あ そう じゃあこれ使ってくださいと言っただけで治りますよ
現実なら 二次的苦しみ作っちゃうと
もうお医者さんにはどうすることもできない
薬は効かない ちゃんと痛みだったら薬は必ず効く
だからブロック注射でもう痛みがない
それで一時的な 1軸がない
1軸がない人には 2軸もありえないし
3軸もない しかし 頭で余計なことを考えて
まあこれただ痛みをやめただけ
治療したわけじゃない
だからこれがまずいと
もしかすると別なところで痛みが出てくるんじゃないのかとか
あれこれやと妄想してくると
また痛みが出てきます
同じ場所でかって痛かった同じ場所で
しかし それには薬効きません
二次二次苦しみ  外からのあれによって心が動揺しないようにという
それはその感覚が感じる最初の一時的なものは何であるのかということは
まあ痛みである 痛みというのも普通に痛いということじゃなくて
もうちょっと別の意味だと思うんです
要するに 外から何か光とか
外から何かが入ってきて
それに対する まあ言ってますから
まあ反応するわけです
その反応を 体の動きの反応ですかね
反応というか だから一時的な反応はもう自然に起こりますから
それはもう例えばまず何か食べたらまずいと感じたらまずい
それだけ終わり あ これはまずいと
それはすぐ生まれるのであって
反応ですよ で それ以上持っていくと二次的な苦しみ
私にとって良くない 人にとって
人にとって良くない反応を良くないと感じるものは痛いとして感じられる
何か 例えばその毒が毒のあるガスが流れてくると
それは本能的にこれは毒だということを体が知っている場合には
それを痛みとして 痛みとはすみませんけども
嫌悪ですかね  嫌悪嫌悪
それが究極的には痛みなんですか
究極的には痛みです 痛みというか
仏教を使う言葉はドゥッカですからね
一応は苦ですと 面白いですよ
体が苦しみでできているんです
苦しみがなくなるとすぐ壊れるんです
幸福でできているわけじゃないんです
だから 毎日のことだから
我々は健康だ健康だと言うんであって
毎日と違っていると変わると大変だ
病気だと言うんですよ
例えば呼吸しているでしょうに
吸うことも苦しいし 吐くことも苦しいんですよ
それがなくなるともう呼吸しないんですよ
それだったら 呼吸しないでいると死ぬほど苦しくなるんだから呼吸する
とにかくこの内臓まで全部苦痛を出すためにはいつでも準備OK状態なんです
普段感じない大腸 小腸
胃 なんだらかんだら もうもう全部調子悪くなるとすぐ苦痛は出してくれるんですよ
これみんなこの感想がもうもう手遅れになるまでわからないでしょ
すごいやばいことで なんか感想はあまり痛いという信号を出してくれないんですよ
乾燥だけプログラムされている方法はなんかとにかく頑張ってみなさいと
だって食べ物やらあれこれ全部この体に必要なように管理しなくちゃあかんから
悪いものは入るなと文句言えないでしょ
乾燥には乾燥でしたっけね
パンクレアス だから悪いものをどんどん
そんなこと言ってる場合じゃない
そちらの仕事だから 脂肪はどうするのかとか
タンパク質はどうするのかとか
だから乾燥だけ 人間の場合はもう完全に機能停止するまでわからないんです
他大体はわかります それでも論理的には乾燥も調子が悪くなると
もう痛みとしてどこかに信号を出さなくちゃいけない
乾燥そのものにはその信号を出すことできない場合は別なところで代弁するんです
例えばガンなんかの場合は実際痛くはないんです
普通 初期時代では でもそれでも大きくなってくると
いろんなところで代弁してくるんです
体が だからお医者さんにしたら大変ですよ
だってみんなちょっと調子が悪いとかね
なんか食欲はあまりないんで
ちゃんと食べてますけど
どうも体力が出てこないとかね
そういういろんなことを言うんです
だから 原因なんなのかとお医者さんがもうすごい検査して調べなくちゃいけない
それはこの患部が自分で直接語れない時なんです
例えばアペンディックスというのは日本語で何といいますか
えっ もうえっ 盲腸 盲腸なんかはすぐ自分で代弁します
自分ですぐ語るんです
真相ははっきりと自分で言うしね
どんなセクションもやっぱりもう痛みだけすぐ感じられるように
いつでも準備 OK なんです
幸福を感じるプログラムはないんです
だからこの生命は苦でできているんですよ
こんな難しいことを考えると頭が悪くなるんだから
単純なことで考えてください
そうすると頭がしっかりします
例えば 私はこの強く手で机を叩く
テーブルを叩くとものすごく気分が良かったとしてください
ああ 気分がいいと快感だと
私はどうしますか？もう一回叩く
もう一回叩く 止まれなくなっちゃうんです
そこで怪我して 手が折れて骨が折れて
もうもう何て言いますか
切断したっても ずっと叩くんですよ
やめることは不可能になるんです
しかし 幸いに不注意ででも手が机にぶつかるとものすごく痛いんですよ
それでも気をつけろと
そういうわけで 苦が我々の命を守って支えて維持しているんです
しかし そこは矛盾ですよ
苦しいんだから お医者さんに行ってなんとかしてちょうだいとも言うし
で 感染感覚消しちゃうと人は死んじゃいます
だから医学の世界ではものすごい危険なのは麻酔なんですよ
危険ですよ もし目が覚めなかったらどうしましょう
死にます だから大手術の場合は感染麻酔するし
その時は苦を完全ブロックするんですね
でもそれがいいわけじゃないんです
苦を完全にブロックしちゃうと
心臓はもう機械任せにしなくちゃいけないし
呼吸も機械任せにしなくちゃいけないし
それからずっと機械で血圧が大丈夫かとチェックしなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 痛みがないんだから
血圧もどんどん減ったりします
そうなってくると脳細胞がイカれちゃいます
だからこの手術そのものはどうったことはないんです
切って貼っちゃえばもう治ります
その時間で人のお医者さんいるとこ
私はそんなこと喋ってはいけませんだけどね
でもこの麻酔かけて その間でこの命をつなげることが大変なことなんです
だからこのアネステシスやってるお医者さんが
それをすごいちょうどいいところに設定しておかないと
それから手術もできるだけ早くやるでしょ
別にゆっくりお茶飲んできて
ちょっと一休みをしてやっても大丈夫ですよ
別にお医者さんが切るところだから
別に血液が流れて流れて死ぬとか
それはほとんどないし
それはちゃんとガードをちゃんとやってますよ
だから体を開けたままでも
時間経っても大丈夫ですけど
問題はそれじゃないんだ
麻酔なんです だから手術する場合は
医者がすごい勢いで ものすごい早く終わるのに終わりにします
早くも麻酔のスイッチを切りたいんですよ
そういうことで 命に苦が苦しみが必要なんです
はい  じゃあ長くなりましたが
まだですか？じゃあもう一回
あのですね 悟りを開いた人に子供がいたとして
その子供が誘拐されたりやられたりどうされたとしても
苦しみは感じないのかということと
過去生 例えば 例えば自分が何か犯した罪を返してくれとかというようなことを悟りを開いた人からというのは
そういうことを言うのか
言わない 黙って黙って何もしない
あのちょっと通訳しないとちょっとあまり聞き取れなかったんです
悟りを開いた人ですね
の子供が殺された場合
その人の子供がですね
殺された場合 悟りを開いた人はどういうような
なるほど あ それはまあ
まあ仮定の話になりますけどね
まあ悟りを開いた人はその時点で子供に対する執着はありません
その代わりに一切の生命に対する慈しみはあります
だから助けてあげることなら助けてあげるでしょうと思います
助けてあげることも何もできなくて
もうすぐ連れて行かれて殺したならば
そうかということで終わります
それからもう一つ はい
やっぱり悟りを開いた人の親戚の子供が北朝鮮によって拉致された場合
どういう対応をしますか
そこを仮定の話ですから
危ないで返事するのは
ただの仮定の話でしょう
まあ本当のところはもう悟りに達した人が悟り前の子供でしょうし
一旦悟ったらもうそういう問題はすべて消えます
そういうことはならないんです
結局は 悟った人は自分で攻撃を受けたりする可能性はあります
過去の業ある場合は まあ周りは幸せになりますよ
だからあまりありえないんです
だから それは具体的なケースがなければ
もう全く語れないしね
仮定で喋るって あんまり私は仮定で喋るのはあんまり上手じゃないんで
まあこれは言えますよ
私は今考えたのは もし私の誰かが北朝鮮に連れて行ったならどうしましょうかと
それだったら私は何のことなくチキタ町に行って
見事に話して連れて帰る
その能力はあります どんな人の気持ちでも
その気になったらこちらの方向に変えてもらうというね
だから私にもそれできるんだから
もう悟った人はね 何のことなく連れてくると思います
木々の例えというのがあったと思うんですけども
誰かが木々を持ってきて
前の首を切るって言ったりしたらば
黙って黙って切られるのがいいのかな
また木々をですね 持ってきた
お前の首を切ると言われたら黙って切られたり切られるんです
いい やっぱりあのまず言いますよ
言わなきゃ ダメなんですね
あなたの首を切るそうとのことで
はい どうそうと いうよりは
あのね そういうことであなたは不幸になりますよと
あなたにとっては一つも幸福にはなりませんよと
だから別に命はどうったことはないんですけど
それはあなたにとって良くないんだから
やめた方がいいんじゃないの？というところは言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
そんなことうるさい もう切るぞと思って切ったら
もうしょうがないんです
一つは言いますよ 一応大菩薩さんは 500歳
500歳じゃないんですけど
いくつか起こしたでしょうに
お釈迦様最初に最初に言ったんです
それそれはやらない方がいいんじゃないのかと
それでもやるぞと言ったら
はい どうそうということになるんです
知ったもんじゃないんだよと
ありがとうございました
石田さんあれですか？じゃあこれを最後
あの 先生が先ほどおっしゃったその深層的な波の話で
その深層的な波の不安感というのはなかなか消しがたいものがあるということですけど
それを例えば仏教徒的な概念で
物事は無常だからとか
無我だからとか 苦はちょっとすぐにわからないから
例えば合論的に考えて善行を結果がすぐあるなしにしろ
やるしかないんだという感じで
その波を全然気にしないというやり方というのは
これは偏見とも言いがたいし
でもなんかドグマ的に捉えると偏見的であるかもしれないという気もするんですけど
どういうふうに  まあドグマ的にとっては
ブッダの教え ドグマ的にとって見ても
見方正しいんだけど 問題は効き目があるかないか
この深層の波が消えたのかと
例えばもう世の中そんなもんで無常でしょうと思ったところで
この不安感消えたのかと
だからそこが問題なんです
だから できるだけものを見たり聞いたりするときは
まあ興奮しないで 執着もしないで
無常の流れでしょう自分もないと
そういうふうに自分に言い聞かせて言い聞かせて
落ち着いて落ち着いている場合は
どんどんどんどんまあ大体感じない程度にはなります
実際はもうヴィパッサナー瞑想で
この心理の流れを自分で経験しない限りはもうしっかり消えません
これ 悟った人と悟ってない人のみんな知りたがるでしょう
これなぜ難しいかと言わないし
もし心の波動をチェックできれば
みんな失敗しますよ だってまずい
これはまずいでしょうと言ったりする可能性はいくらでもありますよ
例えば悟ったっても もし親しい人だったら
言いたいことなんのことなく言ったりする
痛いところ これは痛いと
この階段は私は登れませんから運んでくれとかね
なんのことなく我儘を言うんですよ
やっぱり一般人と同じやと
あれ違います あの二次的な波がないんです
だから上辺のことではなくて
二次的な波をチェックできれば
それがないと感じたら
まあ結構進んでいる人なんです
二次的ではなくて 深層の波
あ いいよ いい エピソードがしまして
これはスリランカの世界ではね
よく昔からある話で いわゆるこの論理はね
で あるお坊さんが悟っていると
で よくお話があって 王様か誰かかな
やっぱり調べたいんですね
ただみんな言ってるだけ
本人言わないんだからね
それで森とか このそういう藪のところで散歩していると隠れていて
ヘビに噛まれたような感じるような
足のかかとの方がプクッとこうやって爪でやっても手を取ったんですね
だから後ろからやったんだから
見えない それと 悟ってないならば
不安感 恐怖感があるでしょう
いきなり飛び上がってどうしようかと
すぐもう出ます 恐怖感が
それはただ ただ何かに挟まれたとぐらいでするのかと
そういうことをしたんだと
最近のもう最近って言ったって
イギリス植民地になる前に仏教を復活したお坊さんのタイからね
お坊さんたちを呼んでね
王様と一緒にやった活動だから
王様がそのお坊さん 悟ってないんだからね
ないんですけど やっぱりそれでもちゃんと戒律を守っているしっかりしたお坊さんでしょうかと
このタミル人王なんですけど
知りたかったんですね
自分が信頼しているんだからね
で もう社会活動も激しくやっているし
それで王様が何やったかというと
全くも言わないでお寺に行ったんです
お寺に行って この一つの手だけ女性の手のようにすごくお化粧いろいろして
女性が入れる指輪 腕輪とかね
全部 王様って言っても贅沢だから
体もそんなにもうね 普通の労働者とは違うでしょうしね
それでお坊さんが昼一人で部屋でいる場合は
窓から何のことなくすると手を出したんだと
手だけ お坊さんには女の手で見えるんだからね
どんな反応するでしょうかと
これちゃんと戒律守っている坊さんともチェックするんですからね
それでまあそこはエピソードを書いてます
書いてる 記録しているものですけど
そこでお坊さんが何のこともなく
ある一つ歌一つ歌ったみたい
そのすぐ瞬間で で まあ信頼できる
この美しい手は いつ見ても大変
私は感動します ありがたがりますよと
我々のことも心配でよく助けてくれる
この美しい手はもういつ見ても飽きませんよという風に言ったら
やっぱりやっぱりバレたかと
そういう風に まあやっぱりずるいことなんですけど
もう悟り開くとそこがなくなるんですね
この心臓の波が だから悟ったと知ってます
他は別にね 例えばニンジン嫌い人は悟ってもニンジン嫌いですよ
それは物理的なセクションだけ
サーリプッタ尊者がアマトでしたからね
で 信者さんもそれ知っていて
大ある大阿羅漢でしょうに
やっぱりサーリプッタ尊者にお布施できれば
いろいろお菓子とか用意してお布施する
それ信者さんも喜んで
欲張りとかの話じゃないんです
どうせすごい知識系の人っていうのは結構アマトなんですよ
理由は科学的な理由はわかりませんだけど
日本の亡くなられた中村元先生も結局アマトなんです
あれほどお年なのに 喫茶店に行って何を注文するかというと
ソフトクリーム それ見て
やっぱりなんか知識の人々なんか同じみたいな
まあそこはもうどうったことはないんですけど
やっぱりこの心臓の波
心臓の波がもう綺麗に消える
だから経典にいろんなところで恐怖がないとか書いてるでしょ
不安がないとかね 恐怖がないとか
いつでも安らぎでいるんだろうとかね
だから悟りを表現するところは
いつでもこの心臓の波がないことを言っているんです
雨が降ったら阿羅漢であろうとも
これはきついんですよ
私は雨が降っても気にしませんよという話じゃ言ってないんです
よくチェックしてみてください
この真言仏教 仏教みたいなことで
この肉体的なあれこれと全くないんです
虹の心臓の波がないことだけを歌っているのです
はい それで終了いたしましょう
回向の文 法灯の三宝に会得し
釈迦の命の祖はサンシヨによって繋がったこの功徳
阿弥陀前祖 祖母 両親 親族
同志をはじめとし 一切の人と死生のものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての人と生き物が幸福に生きさせられ
そして手助けられますよう
サンベティヨウィバンジャントサンダローボウィナッサトーマテーバワトアンテアヨースキーリーガイコーバガ
バトゥサンダマンガラムラッカントサンダデバタサンダブッダヌバーレーナサンダラッマーヌバーレーナサンダサンガーヌバーレーナサダーすってーバワントゥティー
アビワダナシーリッスーニッチャンワンダーバチャーイノーチャッターローダンナーワンナンキリヤユワンノーすかんばれん
サードサードサード  では
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます